we love the banter that you have
with your bro ryan reynolds man wiggling
on a lot of banter this morning
i'm sure she's got any nomination that's
just crazy
that's crazy not because you don't
deserve it
well blake just texted me he said he
won't get out of bed
he's furious he's very angry with the
academy anyway you know
i reached out to him i said if you need
help with anything just reach out
it's the faux feud these two just won't
quit
ryan reynolds is a complete and total
he dishes it out all right yeah but
sometimes he's got to force feed him
back
apparently hugh can't catch a break at
home with his family either
you're such a ray of sunshine i wish i
could show you a picture of my kids who
just roll their eyes at the ray of
sunshine
fine tell your kids dad is super cool
okay so no eye roll
over there your daddy that was perfect
because my daughter just came up behind
i roll number two there it was i got a
15 and a 20 year old so let's be honest
they don't really want to spend their
summer with the parents so and i'm just
sort of standing around like a little
puppy dog like
i don't want to do anything and i don't
watch anything like no
the deckman family of four have been
hunkering down in the hamptons and the
dapper 51 year old star
cleaned up his quarantine look just for
us i'm surprised you're not rocking a
little beard action you had a little i
wasn't
i was until about two hours ago rage
it was and very great i thought i'd put
my best foot forward here
again i want to get back to this
nomination for bad education
i mean do you remember the teachers who
sat with you who held you by the hand
so this is your first acting emmy
nomination
because of course you were recognized
for your work as
hosts for the tony's hugh jackman
what a big night for you very big yes
very i'm
i'm still a little shocked it's a great
honor and you know i've been in the
business for 25 years so
even though it's a weird year and a
difficult year i still feel
you know the community will come
together find a way to celebrate do you
foresee yourself
going to participate if it's safe i tell
you
one positive about it being virtual i
will get dressed up
but i can't promise from the waist down